40 this morning school starts for ccsd
in a week and a half and boy we know
that morning grind it can be tough for
parents so let's make it a little bit
easier for y'all mary jane bellies live
this morning with a local nutritionist
to show how to make some quick healthy
and affordable meals for the kids mary
jane good morning to you
yeah good morning to you john and maybe
parents can also start helping and
having their kids help with their school
lunches just to make it part of their
morning routine and make it a little bit
easier this morning i have rudy nava he
is the vice president of performance
nutrition and health and also his son
roman is here with us as well and we
have a really great selection of fruits
vegetables really all types of good food
here and for me it was easy for my
parents to make me a sandwich but that's
not always the case so i know we have
meat roll-ups which is also really
healthy but also a fun way to make lunch
so can you talk about what we have here
absolutely so we have a variety of
fruits and vegetables that kids
typically like and kids are familiar
with and we also have different protein
sources they're going to help keep them
full longer throughout the day so they
can focus on school
he's not a big fan of sandwiches so we
actually take that protein and we find a
creative way for him to eat that during
his lunch hour so an easy thing that you
can do are protein roll-ups that you see
here
you can either do turkey or like a lean
roast beef and really just honestly like
you can roll it up just the meat alone
you can roll it up with cheese and
whatever you'd like to do for your kids
so that they have something that's going
to satiate them and keep them full
we also have for kids that maybe just
don't want to have the the lunch meat of
the turkey the roast beef one day if you
get a good hot dog that's actually
looking for one that has a little bit
more protein than the fats it can do the
same thing it can keep them fuller
longer there may not be as much ultra
processed stuff in them and uh the one
thing we like to do is make little
kebabs that are fun for romans so i know
roman you want to show them how you do
that
you want to cut it yeah okay here you go
there you go oh there you go
perfect there we go and then you just
take a toothpick
pop it in there and obviously just cut
them into sizes so that they can fit
comfortably into your lunchbox and the
kids will be good to go that is perfect
so healthy nutritious fun to make and of
course roman approved
perfect thank you so much to you both of
course we'll be here all morning making
more meals as kids head back to school
reporting live mayor jean valeeza live
local now